exactly you you remember arthur i knew
you remember i was there
right we're now live streaming but uh so
um
sonia will officially tell us when we've
uh
it's up there as live so
be careful
[Music]
okay we're live chairman
thank you we've got um
just a couple of minutes here to go
foreign
good evening everyone welcome to rocha
district council's remote meeting of the
executive
and a warm welcome to anyone watching
this via live stream
um good evening and a warm welcome
we move please to agenda item
number one apologies for absence and
looking around as far as i can see
everyone that should be here is here and
there are no apologies
moving to agenda item two non-members
attended
attending uh sonia can you uh read out
the names please have any non-members of
the executive attending
yes chairman we have councillors mrs
gooding
and mrs belton
thank you for uh your attendance tonight
the non-members of the exec
uh moving to agenda item three the
minutes
uh are the minutes of the meeting held
on the 7th of october
agreed members a great chairman
reid agreed agreed
great great thank you
agenda item five questions on notice
from
councillors there are none so
uh we move on uh from uh
uh item five to six that has referred to
the executive
reports from other committees and again
there are none members so that takes us
neatly onto
the gender agenda item seven
which is the quarter two twenty twenty
twenty one
financial management report and if i can
ask
councillor simon smith portfolio holder
for finance
uh to introduce the report please
councillor smith thank you members
i believe you've all uh seen seen a copy
of the
quarter two report and i've got a
simon you're a mute thank you pardon i
thought i'd unmuted myself
um so i'm going to
read a report to take you through the
quarter two management report which has
been circulated and is
available on the council website the
purpose of the report is to set out the
forecast revenue
and capital budget positions as at the
end of quarter 2
for 2021 the latest revenue budget for
2021
is 10.87 million
changes to the original budget are due
to drawdowns from reserves which are
detailed in appendix 1.
the forecast outrun as at quarter 1
is 10.92 million which gives a small
projected overspend
of 54 000 pounds this assumes
application of the council's covert
grant application
of just over one million and a further
hundred thousand grant was announced
after the report was published but it
does not yet
assume any additional payments for loss
of income
under the government scheme the covid 19
pandemic is expected to have significant
impact
on the council's financial position both
in 2021
and future years although the full
impact is not clear
and it will depend on how quickly the
wider economy recovers
the council is incurring additional
unplanned expenditure
in a number of areas such as support for
leisure services
provision of homeless services and
increased litter collection
it also expects to face losses across
most of its income lines
most notably of which is car parking
the projections within this report are
based on assumptions which have a high
degree of uncertainty
and will therefore be subject to close
monitoring and refinement
over the course of the year as things
further develop
the council has so far received 1.011
million
of on ring fenced grant from central
government
to contribute towards covet 19 related
pressures
and has been notified that it will
receive a further
hundred thousand we are required to
report monthly
on on the expected financial pressures
related to the covid
pandemic and these returns have been
shared with all members
central government has also announced
the scheme to reimburse
local authorities for an element of its
lost income
an initial claim of 288 300 pounds
has been made and further windows for
claims
will be opened later in the year the
council will seek to mitigate
any remaining overspends through in-year
savings
as far as possible but does have
reserves to draw on
if required ideally as a last resort
no longer-term kovid related funding
beyond
2021 has yet been announced but there is
a strong possibility
that some of the income losses and the
cost pressures experienced this year
could be found into 21 22 and
beyond the position will continue to be
closely monitored
over the financial year with assumptions
being updated for budget setting
as appropriate the council is likely to
have to take
difficult decisions to ensure its
financial sustainability
in the medium term unless significant
additional
ongoing resources are agreed for local
authorities
in the budget settlement the spending
review is expected to take place
on the 25th of november with the local
government settlement
expected two or three weeks after that
the original capital program for 2021
was reprofiled in quarter one and the
revised budget is now
1.969 million
the forecast outrun on the council's
capital programme as at quarter 2
is 1.824 million the table is attend
appendix 3
summarizes the projected position by
service
area that takes you through
the highlights and of the low points of
our financial position
happy to take questions with the help of
naomi lucas our 151 officer
thank you council smith thank you very
much indeed members are there any
questions
uh councillor ward
thank you leader it's an observation as
much
as anything on on 7.25
just how disastrous the income has been
in regards to parking um
it really really has shown you know
the type of deficits we're facing where
car parking is one of our major incomes
and i think it should be noted
that um you know that this is an
important income
for the council and i think you know
members of the public
should realize just how valuable and
important it is
to help us to balance the books and
provide a lot of the statutory services
that they
expect thank you chad thank you council
award
i think there was a statement rather
than a question so i'm not sure it calls
for any uh
particular response unless you wanted to
uh well
all i would say is is that um
we obviously in quarter one were
completely in lockdown
we had a degree of recovery in court
quarter two
and you could have foreseen a little bit
of optimism in the way
figures might have recovered but as a
mentioned in the report there's a great
degree of uncertainty
the biggest of which is now is now
starting at midnight tonight for four
weeks
thank you council smith if i can turn to
councillor fd
thank you chairman um
appendix 2
page 711 let's go back to that screen
again
with the um
lost the screen uh
7 11 conducting elections and
registration of elect
electors i can understand registrations
of electors because we've got to do that
but why have we got a
draw down of 40k in
quarter two of conducting elections when
we didn't or am i
totally lost here um
i can't answer the detail of that one
myself
i don't think you would maybe introduce
that one to
naomi
thank you chair um i i think i might
just have to take that away and come
back to your written answer on that just
so i can double check
and if that's okay yes fine
any other questions members i can't see
anyone indicating
and if that is the case
i will take you back to page 7.1
and refer you to item 1 1.1 the decision
being
recommended and that is to note the
quarter 2
20 20 21 revenue budget
and capital position set out in sections
three and four
and details in appendices one to four
uh is that noted members no did not
tweeted
no chairman thank you
very much then that concludes the
business for this evening's meeting
uh thank you very much indeed uh for
attending thank you to
members of the public thank you to
non-members
and i will declare the meeting